[Music]
kick-ass okay so this movie's been
pretty hyped up but it's really easy to
relate to the premise because as the
movie addresses we've all thought about
being a superhero and fighting crime I
mean just be honest with yourself so the
movie kick-ass follows a Peter Parker
s-type high school nerd as he decides to
suit up and kick ass as the superhero
will kick ass and at first he hits a bit
of a rough patch yeah he gets his ass
beat but he soon finds his groove and he
becomes a superhero and a YouTube
phenomenon
he then meets up with other superheroes
like red mist
aka McLovin Big Daddy which is
straight-up Nicolas Cage his best role
since Conair and the vulgar sarcastic
and badass hit girl hit girl straight up
makes this movie I mean at a point you
realize you like Big Daddy and Hit Girl
a lot more than you actually like
kick-ass but barring a couple of moments
this is hit girls show man I mean she
wasted a roomful of thugs with a spear -
the theme song - the banana splits yeah
I was pretty much on her side after that
most of the best lines best action and
best moments in this movie involve Hit
Girl I mean she flips off of walls and
flips off of people's head she's like a
little nine-year-old ninja love a gun I
mean that is kick-ass right there so the
main villain that our heroes need to
take down is played by Mark Strong who's
straight-up like the Sam Worthington of
villains it's like in 2009 someone was
like we need a new villain in movies bad
about Mark Strong he kind of looks like
Andy Garcia but he was a really good
villainous organized-crime Duchenne
kick-ass so I'll give him that this
movie was kind of like zombie land for
superheroes how was a really comedic
twist on a really ridiculous premise but
it still has those serious moments that
keep it grounded you know and a lot of
blood a lot of blood here it is think
super bad meets Kill Bill meet
spider-man's really evil rated-r
stepbrother best I can do to describe it
now right off the bat you go into this
movie wanting to see some kick-ass
kick-ass but the movie although funny
and filled with really witty commentary
takes a little while to get to that
point most of the kick-ass badassery
takes place in the second half of this
movie but kick-ass has laughs throughout
so it's not like the first half is
boring at all is actually funny as hell
just saying I actually really want to
read the kick-ass graphic novels now so
you've been waiting for kick-ass for
months now it's out it's vulgar it's
funny it's badass you might want to
leave the kids head home for this one
but go see it it's a lot of violent and
vulgar [ __ ] fun
I will not say the phrase kick ass kicks
ass because everyone says that but I
really do want to because it really does
and if you like this [ __ ] this review
that is the YouTube keeps moving the
sidebar around left down up right I
don't know where it is now but if you
want to see more reviews you can go to
my page by clicking here and you might
want to subscribe if you talk kick ass
kicked ass
[Music]